plus il ya quelque chose dans l'air
quelque chose de mauvais cap raffut
désobéissants
formés
tu as vu coller des affiches pour
retrouver ton frère je peux t'aider dans
ton temps tu crois que si j'avais besoin
des gisements clochard comme toi je
m'appelle aube et je peux te donner du
pouvoir pour retrouver ton frère mais
vous devez être deux habitants non salée
mais j'ai besoin de temps avec dedans
donc tu restes pour nous tous à ce
schéma j'ai 15 ans tu peux pas lui faire
confiance à toi je te fais confiance
53 euros vent non médicaux prononcé
gratuit mon frère y a rien que je fais
pas
[Musique]
c'est toi qui est pour moi c'est comme
une drogue
j'ai deux filles sophia qu on peut
manipuler leurs manuels obs laissera pas
faire
[Musique]